back to the Naya Rivera tragedy that
unfolded here at Lake Piru as
authorities try to piece together what
went so horribly wrong
[Music]
that's the 9-1-1 call placed by the
company who read an ayah and her son
Josie the pontoon boat
he was found adrift on alone was her son
in the water it's my understanding that
he was swimming in the water
I don't know how if he got into the boat
on his own accord or if his mother
helped him
mother and son head out onto the dock
and later launched the boat in what
could be
nya's final hours alive now authorities
continue to use boats and helicopters in
their search of this Lake but it has
become a recovery effort and let me tell
you why it is so hard to find a body
that could be submerged here look at
that brush over there that's what's at
the bottom of his Lake do you have lots
of trees and that's what's hampering
divers the divers are in the water with
no visibility that they have to search
with their hands it can take anywhere
from four to seven days before we start
to see that a body will resurface has
she swam in this Lake before I don't
know what kind of swimmer she is she's
been to this lake before she's been out
on a boat on this lake before Maya grew
up nearby here and in 2011 told us about
her ideal summer activities
[Music]
before landing gleen I started her
career modeling and Barbie adds her
first TV gig was at age 4 starring on
the sitcom the royal family alongside
Della Reese and jackée Harry I pray
Harry we were on set with the adorably
shy star she was the same age as her son
Josie is today it tired because you have
to because because you have to because
you have to get your lines every day
well made
Naiya skyrocketed to fame on Glee but
she called becoming a mom to josie quote
my greatest success I want to be here
for him and I don't want to miss
anything and and you know I'm gonna
navigate the right way to do that
everything's already ordered and
numbered so I'm not too worried about it
[Music]